[Music]
hello
hello everybody what is up oh my gosh
okay
it's not i know it's been a long time
since we've been here for some good ol
game spot live action but we are here
now apex legends has
just dropped the first of a very
extended series of ltms so over the next
few days
it's gonna be the first one and then the
second and then the third and then
so on and so forth it's going to be
pretty awesome but the first one that is
up
is the second chance playlist i am super
excited
and i'm going to be running some games
today with the homies i got k-series
and i got denny both of them are very
very
important people to me you know very
awesome friends of mine
um so yeah we have danny pawn here and
casey roos who are going to be playing
some games with me
case ruse and i have actually entered
algs for apex a few times so
you know we are definitely obsessed with
this game we are
you know looking forward to this ltm we
definitely would be playing it today
well
me a little bit later on i'm sure casey
already but
we would be we'd that definitely be
playing so i'm excited that we actually
get to stream it have some fun
and denny pond actually started playing
apex a month ago
so anybody tuning in thinking oh you
know we're already at the end of season
eight
it's way too late to join in absolutely
not you can
join in whenever you're you might like
it she's been learning more of the
lauren stuff too
the game is very awesome very
interesting i'm excited to play and
check out the modes
but i'm also excited to be back for some
game spot live
oh it's been a minute
so yes thank you guys for waiting
while we get started and i'm just gonna
toss it out there while it has been a
while
um you know since we've been here for
some game spotlight we were on time
we're ahead of time two minutes
ahead of time all right that's a big
deal for me
so yeah it's exciting um
so yes i actually have some information
here about the ltm's second chance
um is the one we're playing today today
is going to be going on for the next few
days
and this one basically gives you a
second
respawn you'll respawn where you died
and you
keep all your stuff this is gonna be um
obviously there's gonna be some
badges you can't unlock in this because
it'll be too easy with the help of the
ltm
so sorry for anyone who wanted to try to
get those up
which one is it assassin
so it should be interesting also when i
play i usually don't have the music on
but i have put the music on now and
horizons bae
i got her theme on of course i'm gonna
kick the bucket someday
let me make sure we are nearly at 22.
i know we're getting there we're getting
there
the chat what's up everyone in chat yo
brandon hernandez
always showing up no matter when you're
always
aware i know always on time
loyal wherever
your heart desires where can we get the
most
out of our second gym game
oh yeah button checks first game button
option select option select glory
[Applause]
sounds about right so each legend
responds above the position they were
eliminated
once per match intervesting
ooh you know gotta gotta spin on them
real quick
sharif's in the chat what is good
i'll show you guys if you haven't seen
we have a new video
uh valerie clips of the week another
fps oh no why are they giving me this
combo
he's
i think there's someone else that's
another squad
bloodhound
careful daddy i'm coming up behind you
oh yeah true i am out here
you don't want the shield yet
author up there okay one is a triple
take
oh nice skin okay these new teamsquad
yeah yeah let them fight let's fight for
a second
okay we're good all right let's go ruin
their day
oh bro i got another star bro
wait i fall hold up you're fine you're
fine we're good we're good oh
nice oh she's cute
oh she's in the corner he's in the
corner he's in the front oh man oh no
danny
[Music]
oh this is cool wait how do i get back
oh okay okay
that was definitely not the smart
opening
yeah i definitely should not have went
back to that same spot
i can't i'm gonna i'm landing in this
dangerous out of map
here i tested it for you guys don't go
back over there
yeah yeah yeah perfect perfect hold on
no that's
it fine pretty cool though so far it's
gonna be a rescue attempt right here
okay oh that's another another thing
i know i just definitely got ripperoni
right there
i gotta get off though
you would have been dq'd right there
[Applause]
algs
you got
[Laughter]
it's okay you got that other guy level
three
you got that other guy lova
don't happy does it mean
the loba just came down and she was like
hello oh how's it going
that was interesting falling from the
sky i was like minecraft creative mode
all of a sudden
i know for a moment i was like well
gigi is going back to my scene i'd
already forgot we were playing lcm
just that fast that fast that was it was
so
it literally was like crazy that was
chaotic
having to kill the same people over and
over again what the heck that was kind
of cool though because you kept all your
stuff yeah it was nice i came back with
a full shield and
uh you know a gun
all right so now that we have a better
idea
i know if if if things really go haywire
and i die i'm just going to fly
somewhere else easy as that yeah
it's kind of cool too because get the
job done it kind of encourages your team
to push
really really aggro one time at least
yeah
right because if you all die you could
just respawn and go somewhere else
yeah well it's also interesting
you don't know if they have their extra
lives here
that's
so that's a good amount of time when i
went introducing your
okay
so number right after the game i know
some of the rewards are not
um being awarded
but also yeah maybe it's just some new
touch but happening right now
i have been looking forward to this but
of course as my
as my rng would have it the one i'm
looking forward to the most is the last
ltm
[Applause]
it's okay i gotta put as much love into
lifeline as i can before
i'm nerfed in season nine i'm trying
to shop another sized lunch oh is there
people here
inside yeah
i saw a team land at or is it
was it containment one right next to us
oh can't really see them but they're
definitely
oh my lordy
i'm far away
oh no oh no
they got all the traps oh they got
watson a classic and a rampart yeah
they went 100 ham actually
don't come and shoot me okay i was
trying to survive as long as possible
all right um did you guys drop right
back down
uh oh i see you i see you i see you
there's another team coming into them so
i'm not going over there oh yeah
bye-bye i'm out of here oh my gosh
there's
so many people
there will be um yeah there are a lot of
people
well it's just those teams two teams
there and there's two teams outside too
i need lightning badly
uh i can give you a stack okay
wait what are you doing i'm just using
an uh light oh
yeah they're going enough over there
i'm just chilling here i mean it's a
ceiling man
oh yeah there's one man in this
don't be toxic
they stopped raining down from above i
am going to make my way over there but
up on the
wall of the air base oh no wait wait
wait wait wait and again you're still
fighting oh you are
over there my bad my bad i'm on my own
it's okay
[Music]
[Music]
there is a lot here
yeah there's one with a purple shield
oh
oh my god someone gave me your
that was actually super him i
actually felt terror from that when they
died and i saw the green box so i was
like what do you mean
you're not actually dead
game voice volume is a little high all
right let me see if i can turn it on
well that was wild we only came in tenth
place
that was
[Laughter]
honorary first game of the day
when you had played a ram yeah and lose
i was just constantly sick first game
first game
all first game first game yeah
uh first time whatever champ you're
playing
yeah yeah you know i don't even really
play this game so first time ring guys
sorry guys
[Laughter]
it gives me like um a recon panda
or recon teemo was definitely playing a
ranked game when this skin first came
out
and sat in the corner no one saw me
i don't want zombies this skin's
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
been a little bit of a friend of me for
quite yeah exactly
he's a little toxic oh one two three one
team
very shiny
did no one land up here i don't i didn't
see the team
down at the bottom yeah
[Music]
and i have a gift
see you guys when you play with friends
for a long time they know
exactly what your loadout is and you
never have to worry about finding your
gun ever again
like that it's pretty
um
i'm hearing the sniper tower going up on
the other side i hear people walking
around i don't know
oh yeah midfield
oh they don't have a turbocharger though
um
right
i can't believe that they're shooting
at us in a shooting game
they're shooting at us
cracks
oh
oh my goodness there's a sniper over
here watch out oh no she's coming in
behind us
no
[Music]
i don't know i didn't see their pathing
they're up there okay
i'm out of cells by the way so i'm gonna
try to like
get out of here i just don't have the
range to fight them like this
oh thank you
[Music]
oh
do we just run behind i don't even know
where the ring is supposed to be i'm
running
[Music]
oh my gosh they're tasting they're
tasting
one of them's coming through down here
i'm
up here guys i'm like okay
i am running i don't know about you guys
but i'll put
my forest gump shoes on and i am getting
out of here
i have nada to my name and those shields
yeah she's dropping in right now yeah
that horizon thirsted me before she was
out for blood
no i need that i just need skin
i
[Applause]
no idea if there's anything on it but
try uh i have found some shelters
hallelujah
[Music]
i have i have 700 damage
[Music]
yeah this is
[Music]
[Music]
all right
does that mean healing items i know
right shield cells
squishy
[Music]
social cells on this side so fast
thank you tricking me
man you know i would say this ltn is
great
and i'm glad we have lives to square but
we don't have lives to spread
unfortunately i would like to burn the
lime super early
but gonna be up there
if it wasn't for that we would have been
dead
but would people have been going as him
if
that's all they didn't know they'd be
respond
never stop going ham scanning the area
it's okay dragon boy it's okay dragon
boy
relax it's all gonna be fun nothing
[Music]
i'm gonna go check over here
[Music]
[Music]
um i don't want to get the holes right
now
as much as i don't like going to my
graveyard up there you might have to run
through them
i say yeah package over that one you
are correct i will go that way
yeah they're wild and crazy
oh my god yeah they work
even though it was stressful at the
moment it was pretty fun
i got a gold knockdown and uh
purple stalk and a medkit you know
living
we're not dead yet
[Laughter]
hmm
[Music]
let me that
actually forget it oh i didn't get
unscanned so if they are they're not
close enough i don't see any
footprints packaging
what was that though that was you
yeah just make sure no one's running in
behind us yeah we definitely
can't scan in two seconds
oh there we go
replicator on its way down hmm should we
go the other way
there's a mirage right there oh schnapps
okay
should we go let's go oh i see i see on
my screen
are they right there i see angle or
smoke
[Music]
oh
running running running
oh my goodness i couldn't finish point
like
purple shield what the heck
two back there someone else turning
around
i have no throwables
oh
oh
okay yeah there's a sniper across just
keep trying to keep moving up
here i have a feeling there's someone up
top yeah someone in
um over there across in our favorite
area
i know this area
[Music]
i'm gonna use all my cells i don't want
to wait here
i'm going to take that actually i don't
have one
i only saw one person come up on the
skin but yeah all the way at the bottom
over here oh my god it's the rip squad
i can't
yeah the person was here and ran i think
it's a solo because there's ten people
in four squads so
wow we're rich rich actually rich oh
it's a problem
they ran this way
they're still back there they're pushing
and they're pushing and they're pushing
they're pushing the other squad yeah
let's come back up here because
next ring is
well that was weird i just tried to
mantle and i got
shot up into the air oh what the heck
yeah there's a squad in the building
below us
i hear their feet
because they're like directly under here
someone's down there he's probably gonna
try
i'm gonna try not to take any
unnecessary damage without having any
more bounce
same
where uh the shooting coming from far at
the long run right here
wait whose feet are those that's why
your face okay i'm turning around right
now i'm turning around right now
it's a mirage it's a mirage it's a
mirage all right but that means that
they're back yep yep
oh my gosh
yeah one second yeah on the left
oh
oh my goodness let's see if he jumps it
or not
nope that was it eliminated
let's come
all right
i think there was a spot over there but
there's definitely one behind this wall
here
over there i put a shield in here that's
a fall
level
i do have someone outside behind us
maybe yeah we just pulled this building
hold on hold on there's someone behind
us there's someone behind us north side
yeah yes yeah
yeah they're rushing in on us we're good
we're good we're good
let me get away from the window
[Applause]
yeah i'll go like at 30 seconds again
yeah there's someone on the roof on this
back side corner right here yeah
so if we go up we need to look
you want to go out that side the
southeast door you all see stores
it's kind of in the ring and i don't
want to take unnecessary ring damage
someone jumped off they're not i have
they're not on this night
okay i really ready
someone does have a sniper out there so
yeah
anybody have a heat shield by chance yes
i have one
okay oh she just climbed the top right
there
if you want to stay here i haven't eaten
yeah we might need
as well for like a second
maybe with them maybe perhaps all right
throw the heat shield
when it gets close to it i'm gonna yeah
i'm gonna hold the shield right here
i wonder how many lives they have left
[Music]
go go go go
[Music]
cracks
yeah the heat shields like got
immediately imploded by the ring
i thought it would last for like one
more second to give us a chance
to be fine
that was definitely final ring though
yeah
no it was
oh the mirage just kept jumping in oh he
still had his second chance ooh
imagine like multiple squads at the end
and they all have their second chance
in the last rings that would be insane
kind of
i just want to watch this yeah i don't
know why our heat shield blew up
that was hysterical all of them just
like looked up into the air and started
shooting by the way oh my goodness
that's funny
um i actually prefer the prowler not in
full auto i think it's much better in
burst fire for those in the chat
wondering
it definitely used to be better full
auto but when it got put into the care
package and the damage got buffed
uh the ttk on the burst just is way
better than the water
yeah i agree better i feel like every
single time i get a legendary weapon
i get to use it for all of two seconds
before i'm mowed down by an enemy team
it's super
upset i'm like what the heck i mean we
just can't have you running out here
you know what i really do like
i know thank you honestly thank you put
in the limiters
yeah that was a really good try though i
feel like we were
lacking resources for a long time
i know i was upset about that that that
shield though
one second i guess we could have loaded
them up back to back to back
until but i didn't realize the team on
top of my roof
jumped down way way ahead of time i
thought they were still up there
but when we went out there they were all
over there
yeah right next to us i honestly don't
really know where it would have been
yeah behind
and you only have yourself to blame
almost 200
kills oh so this is your champion
looking about a surprise my 80 year old
mum
that's
yeah i feel like it more than the rings
but i will say that the ring flare event
definitely upped our rotations
i'm like i want nothing to do with this
thing ever again
i feel like we got a lot better moving
fast
there's another team with us i think
[Music]
i uh unless it was our shadows too i
don't know i saw some shadows going
towards
a couple yeah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right where's the random turbo
charger on the ground like
i mean you want an anvil receiver you
want four skull piercers
oh true ample reciprocal i could not
pick up a flatline
question mark
[Music]
oh
they're landing on us they're landing on
us they landed in the town we were just
on
let's go back for them yeah they're
gonna have their stuff though so
oh yeah connected
they actually just kicked me from the
game what the heck
oh no eliminated
oh that was heartbreaking
the scam what the hell
trying to hold me back it's okay
i was ready we'll fight in your honor
yeah i have my alternator spitfire ready
dang they
did they just bounce bounce they bounce
phones well there's nothing here anyways
casey's like dinner though
i see that i see that
man eight damage one kill
let's go one shot one two
oh
such a weird animation
all right so stream we're just gonna act
like that didn't happen
you know yeah that was the morning
yeah yeah yeah yeah the first game
first game first first first game
why do i have so many girls
yeah the r301 is pretty good
we don't have our scanner anymore and
i'm sad i know right all right
all right hotel is gone
it makes me just kind of want to run
straight into a fight so we can go pick
her up
what happened just it's weird that the
game like disconnected me but that also
kicked me completely out of oh yeah
because usually you're able to reconnect
when that
yeah of course our favorite place
whoa whoa watch out on your left there's
two of them
yeah ah red shield
is
[Music]
oh i just needed one bullet to just
graze them a little bit
someone flying down no let me do damage
shoes i can level up my shield
[Music]
oh my gosh my heart it breaks i'm so bad
all right i got my shield level up
that's all i wanted
but now she's coming
whoa she jumped down she dropped down
there's another team down here
goodbye
oh
yeah i feel like this is 20th party
legends
honestly i don't know you know we had
third parties from like
front back side side now from the sky
we have third parties going in it is fun
though i would say it's like non-stop
action
yeah that
gave you caught that work at the end
though
i was much to myself
i feel like i got my hands back in this
game i don't know how it happened but
suddenly
let's go it's all those all those hours
of house flipper and sims
house flipper is legit though
oh thanks chad i tried it was
wild out there it was wild and wacky
there was like three teams
it was crazy i know i freaking love this
game though
it's all good you're here now exactly
you hear that chat
anybody out there who wants to play
never played before it's never too late
to hop in every season feels pretty
fresh to be honest
and the way they balance stuff and add
new stuff
and i just started reading the apex
like more book thing which is really
cool too it gets you invested
yes pathfinder is champion
pathfinder most wholesome character in
the game oh
you are right this game is so good
i love it oh i'm jump master oh snap
let's go
where are we heading on the map so
there's containment
let's go to maybe
here this might be a good place to land
[Music]
okay
[Music]
and i'm like well five damage just
killed me
every time
oh boy
indeed
there are no mysteries of the universe
without breaking a few eggs keep calm
dears
we're already inside the next ring
to my defense i was reloading my gun
i wanna i'm gonna use this i'm risking
my life and limbs for this vegan
i think i just saw a logo yeah
it could be like to the right or in
front but just like cross my peripherals
yeah it feels risky to open freaking
holes
yeah but it's also it's also fun when
you like hang it from like so far away
oh yeah
throw it on the ground
um
i feel like picking the 30 30 is like
what people ping the most empty
oh my goodness oh yeah i will say ipad i
mean the gun
is good though it's just i'm not good
yeah rings closed but
someone is running up on me like you
know five meters away
give me some time to line up my shot
rebuilding wishing us some good luck in
our match much appreciated
i need it my rng is questionable oh my
gosh
okay
oh i need like both of those if y'all
don't want any of them
yeah you can take them
can't wait to get all this gold stuff
and die in 2.5 milliseconds it's gonna
be so great
all right but i gotta
show the chat what double pistol builds
are all about
[Music]
and i better have you meg if y'all see
ya
i thought i heard something big so wait
well they respond
close ish bye maybe it's still here
sniping over there right father killed
me yeah it's containment
definitely has more battle royale field
um eisenhower eyes on pit ice on pit
i think there's a team in here waiting
for a care package
can we get a uh denny scan t let me get
closer
okay i thought i heard like uh some
shuffling
in here yeah they might have heard i
heard a charge rifle out this way though
probably
looks unloaded yeah
package if i can um up this rock please
all right well no one's over here so
let's
get out of here
[Music]
oh god they're having so much fun over
there
ready for her
there's someone who's down over here
is there someone on you oh no i just
uh yeah
oh there's so many boxes and jump pads
over here
smokes there's someone who's going to
have all right
pet pals i protect
uh this line strip lines are blind
the ultimate bamboozler
[Music]
here's a pick me up no i missed
my immaculate play he's all the way here
in the center
no why is climbing so different
that's the point
that was a drop for sure
all right i don't see anyone else on the
[ __ ] yeah that was
the feats only feats i see around here
zero
welcome to the stream i know it's been a
minute
i think the mirage is going to rise
yeah i got bamboozled like four times by
that guy
i don't think it was three people i
think it was just the mirage putting
down
definitely
sounds like containment still or is that
our grave i
[Music]
someone else has my weapons
oh they're over there and that building
oh my god to the front of you left one
of me oh okay okay
i think they have a plastic in there
yeah in here
okay squad up there um
sixty percent i hear someone flying
someone's landing on them
yep
someone else is landing
[Laughter]
oh there's a turbo charger you know
like i was doing good and they're just
like you can't have this
can't have it danny palm's too powerful
thank you to get my 2k badge
[Laughter]
all i do is eat hot chip and get
disconnected from gabe's diet
dang that's
okay you want to go over there you want
to poke from here still
no i'm just poking from here
technically get the um the 2k patch
and i'll have it in my heart exactly
oh okay okay okay he's probably still
doing this yeah
purple film oh there's another team all
uh further south team up there
oh is there a squad up there oh yeah
they're on the zip line right now
as long as no one comes from behind
i'll be fine yeah let me go take a look
there is a care package dropping back
there
[Applause]
die for it though
that finder nothing all right there's
purple shield in there purple backpack
like 10 million squads over here
i wonder what it is about this ltm
specifically that's making
it like hard quit you out of the game
instead of bringing it back in i wonder
if i'm the only one
experiencing it or oh you got a few
people out here in the open field if you
want to try to pick some pops yeah i
know
i was shooting at them before but
there's also a squad in you know
mm-hmm how's it going
i've i've been pot shotting them for a
while it's just like
oh that pink coming here got team coming
here
[Applause]
don't mind my irl leaning guys i just
have to make sure i get out of here
[Applause]
can you give me a second shields
recharging
they just lift it up to you yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
oh one's across one's across it's
another team
um
all right i did not need to switch my
gun right there
don't worry about it yeah yeah we're out
of there
they look distracted by containment at
the moment
oh another care package dropping right
there
please don't be a team in here
all right alive again
you know this mode ain't so bad not too
bad they're getting shot by yet
another squad
there's a respawn beacon purple
[Music]
of how far is it 200
oh i'm actually running on light emma
oh i need two to level up let me grab
some light i'm not going back here
i think i hear it sorry i'm on top of
that yeah i'm gonna uh yeah
no they are i'm gonna move out of here
okay
hmm so next string is definitely coming
in over here
wedding energy ammo
let's see if there's any in here i
thought i saw some
in the back of this tunnel somewhere
i don't see any of the moments i quite
literally think
all of the teams are out this way yeah i
think so
unless there's one very sneaky team back
there
that's where is that team still on top
of the bunker
yeah they
[Music]
oh that's a new team on the left left
someone just wanna i think we should go
here go this way
okay like
[Music]
hmm
okay how close you're at the entrance
okay
should i have their mouth oh right here
there's one at least that i saw they're
full behind here
correct one octane is running back and
forth
horizons what a name that need was sick
oh my god
[Music]
okay
lift it over lift it over again
i know there's another one
[Music]
um i see what you mean about the screen
not showing up
oh yeah like the post-match screen right
oh it says i have zero i got zero damage
times
ryan says i want to play but i'm in
school ding it's okay
focus on your schoolwork once school is
out it'll be here it's not going
anywhere
yeah okay it's not going anywhere
oh you know gotta stretch everyone's
stretch don't forget
yes stretch hydrate oh yeah hydrate your
check
hydrate or dehydrate
we were definitely dehydrating right
there at the end
those charged rifle shots though i know
kept all of them at bay some great time
we had great team shots on that octane
on the left though you'd love to see it
you'd love to see it there's something
about some good
team shots i was definitely team
shotting in spirit
[Laughter]
team chatting with my mind
unfortunately
and you don't res in like from the ltm
do you still keep your stuff
probably not because your box is
actually like on the ground
right yeah i think so yeah so you'd have
to you'd have to go get your box
because when you die with the the
respawn beacon
your box goes green so i know it can
stop you stay here
oh yeah yeah i noticed that yeah
[Music]
runoff
i didn't think you saw me
i was hoping he didn't get a gun
actually when you're innocent
okay i need
[Music]
10 years while i get my health back
don't mind me
nothing
i feel like i hear someone walking or oh
[Music]
one
oh that lifeline's almost dead 51 damage
should i drop on you
i'm also um
yeah okay oh oh so close all right don't
worry about it then get out because
uh this place i'm
oh man there's definitely people over
here too okay
i'm gonna go this direction
i got some good evening but the lifeline
came in
yeah now i saw that from my death screen
i was like oh
get him yeah
extended heavy mother thought you guys
landed on his feet
yeah okay just
that would have been different she said
they would have caught these hands if i
had a shield
i just saw 50 oh wow
oh my god
why does he have a purple shield he's
cracked i know it's horrible
i should have been
stop playing the game early season two i
have no idea how to start again right
now
i mean that's definitely valid i took a
few seasons off as well
i think from like season like four-ish
to like season seven or whichever season
horizon came out i didn't really play
at all um but when i came back to it
it was still super fresh like there was
a new map and all this other stuff
so i would say the best place to start
is just to play
um if there's other shooters you play or
other games that have characters that
have certain abilities try to find
a character that's similar to those in
certain ways
um i like horizon because like i play on
pc but i also play on controller
so her lift and stuff kind of helps
compensate for the lack of like movement
that i have playing on controller
so that's why i like using her and like
a bunch of other little things about her
too
like besides her cute just being super
super good but like her passive lets you
like land on the ground without going
through that whole recovery sequence and
stuff which
really comes in handy a lot of the time
and even though her all is
is kind of tricky sometimes it once you
get used to it
and like how far it to throw it and how
easily you can bounce it off of a rock
or someone's
like your teammate's head or something
like that yeah
every time i'm like i'm gonna all and
then i'm like oh crap i
just bonked it off the back of your head
so so yeah um
if i'm trying to think of like a
beginner-friendly character
it's kind of tough because it really
depends on your style
right like if you don't really like to
rush down that much
then maybe a good character would be
someone like lifeline so you can at
least help
like your team out and you're not really
supposed to be rushing in there like
that anyways this lifeline
but yeah next season i guess we'll see
and also you know maybe find some some
friends
or find a friend or two it definitely
gets easier to
you know stick with it when you're
playing with friends for sure
[Music]
let's go i'm not getting anyone going
over there
nope there's no one going over there
actually uh well this squad just broke
off
but we'll see click our idea
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's get those
oh yeah for sure gotta be careful
slanted away from me there's really no
other gun here though
oh no
[Applause]
daddy can you can i can i can i see
yeah i think i got someone on my
building oh no they're here
no
[Music]
a little choppy all right yeah the
bloodhound in the bangle or floor town
doesn't have a shield
43 blue shield here yeah
right here if you kill the uh lobos
you just have a crack dangler
[Music]
i'm running to you guys
they are they're trapped up here
oh they just dropped down
um i don't think so i just i just down
the road
i don't know what that brings far and
we've got about a minute oh you down
from over there
i have some cells
45 seconds till she closes all right
yes you gotta hit the wingman shots
sometimes they're long
there is like two different squads
respawning over at um
uh labs favorite place
i burned my res token there
we're just gonna try and stay alive yes
we got you i probably didn't need to
burn it but i got scared
valid balance
oh
oh that's a rez beacon oh yeah that's
that um
i forgot what that place is called
capacitor
surroundings it's over there dust or a
flag i thought i saw someone moving
around
uh probably dust going over there
uh we have to move towards the ring
let's do it yeah they're resting on labs
meaning they don't have their tokens
anymore
oh interdusting don't crave for me bros
[Music]
i want to kill them when they come back
yeah
the old's right there oh i know i want
to try to like i think there's multiple
squads
agreed just don't snipe me anyone else
looking at me holding my old
like a goon yeah i have a grenade
got my old thumb right when they that's
if they even come back i don't hear them
fighting at all oh there he goes
oh there it is yes come back
oh no
my trigger finger i i was so sure they
were about to come back
spaghetti everywhere all over the place
down here absolutely i need to like make
my salty
like waste of all feel better
that was rough it feels like they had to
run pretty far they did whatever they
encountered
i think they didn't realize how far this
other team was yeah
which is also a skills bad moment for
the other food
oh they're getting shot by another squad
up there
we could go around that other team up on
the top
right here long flight right there let's
go long plane because i don't want to
get sniped from above
[Music]
[Applause]
oh someone on the left as well
the rev has apex shields yeah let's go
perform yeah
[Applause]
let's go through the portal and then we
can land like this
but
um this town has been looted over here
right here what the heck
guys maybe
[Applause]
what's going on that left side
yeah my respawn is coming up now i'm
okay
[Music]
oh look at these straps yeah you better
oh
someone just
[Applause]
just watch out behind because i just saw
an octane drop behind us
i did not know my bad there's a revenant
down here
oh my god
yeah actual that was hilarious
[Music]
oh my goodness it definitely adds to the
chaos
it is so fit in like the best way
i love that i get to keep my stuff yeah
i'm gonna ready up but i'll be too
sensitive
okay okay
so what is up chat what do you think of
the new game mode so far
and which game mode are you looking
forward to the most
i feel like i'm looking forward to you
like regain your armor
over time mode so there's ultra zones
where there's more than one hot spot i
guess there's auto banners where when
you die you automatically get your
teammates banner which is nice killing
time
that one is going to be the most
impactful one i think where
every time someone dies it reduces the
round timer
so instead of because sometimes and you
guys know this you'll go into pubs
and by the end of round one there's like
three squads left where
where what happened to everyone and then
you those three squads
all the way away sometimes they'll wait
round for round for a round until the
final round and it could be really
like drawn out so i'm interested in that
one but my
my favorite one is definitely the armor
region
where your armor regenerates over time
at a rate of 12 points per second
which is not bad actually
that means people's shields will
out-heal caustics
get tired of five damage
ryan's in the chat what is up to all the
ryan's i hope you're having a great
tuesday
you must be mad alone i am i'm very
overwhelmed
[Music]
um anybody to say as shields it's cold
out here
like this oh they're on top
i thought they were in labs that's fine
that's fine oh they're scoops
there's two blue shields in that
building
oh yeah look there's yes oh wait which
building another one there's another one
in here too
it's in here thank you
[Music]
all right i'm saying go are they in labs
i
oh they're finding someone else but yeah
in labs you want to go for it
yes wait where's that shield oh i
imagined it
wishful thinking there's two blue
shields in here
oh no right here right here right here
right here oh that was a that was a that
was a
barrage
i'm going in on this a lot of people in
here a lot of reloaded
a lot of grenadine
there's three in there no no
i just want to throw my in there and
ruin their day okay nice nice
but they're gonna respawn
oh my goodness
oh god they're dropping back in on them
too rocked on my mozambique
i personally like the alternator
but i do know that the r99 is
very powerful because when i do use
again people go down super fast
if i land my first half of my clip
that's my issue the alternator is a
little more forgiving
it's true i love what people are like
just hold down into the left forehead
do upside down question mark backwards
with your left arm at 80 degrees easy
peasy
no i mean those things are definitely
valid
but when i'm in the heat of battle my
brain is like
recoil pattern just stay alive
i'm like what is left what is what
um i see no one
yeah i know it was real spicy
and then it wasn't open uh
where do we want to go want to go in the
caves or to
the south yeah i need stuff i don't even
have a shield or a backpack
do you uh every shot and die exactly
exactly exactly
very very uh
only two options on the choose your own
adventure with the r9
[Laughter]
a little bit behind you guys i was
indecisive about what i wanted my gun to
be
yeah i was definitely just running
generally untouched
wow there was a 1x one one x in that
entire bin
oh i don't have a backpack i now realize
yes how does that happen it doesn't have
a backpack
backpacks backpacks just slow you down
you know it's like the first week of
animal crossing where you have like
10 pocket pocket space and fantastic
gotta go get a little card that teaches
you how to like maximize your pocket
space
wowzers you're right i do need a
backpack right you right
ain't never told a lot
and i say as i try to pick up something
and i can't
yeah yeah inventory oh wait what is the
no man's sky
inventory stays full or something like
that i've been
d2 flashbacks i am overburdened
there's a deathbox out here i'm just
running
yeah because there's a care package over
there
let's go clean it
we gotta dig me a crater i haven't had
creeper
so long yeah i'd rather the creeper be
on our team
is that it is that in it is
no one shoot me no one shoot me don't
shoot us froze
looks unlooted at least oh no just
kidding there was just one clothes bin
evil shield here
backpacks i know right back there's so
many blue shields here
backpack okay gucci baby
you could take the backpack
qa knock down shield 2
[Music]
where is everyone yeah i don't know i
don't even hear any fighting
they're far wherever they are yo ark
just took out
yeah i too really enjoy bathing in the
blues
so sometimes i would like to bathe
where is everyone please babe in the
balloon
um
i don't know if that octane was solo but
i definitely
[Music]
them yeah i'm just going to keep you
ready real quick yeah
we're on our way we were getting shot up
from market before
i'm not sure if it would i think i think
the austin came from market but then
like
yeah here in this way but he's probably
long gone
or they are probably a long time
oh there's someone over here yeah you
get interested in sniping
uh it's two teams fighting i'm just
seeing cross spray right now
let's watch their corners if this uh
pins like a solo
trying to creep on us i think we're kind
of in a good spot here once the ring
starts closing
right there
what did i just hear something sounded
really close to me
oh i knew it oh my god yo
the
i heard something she tried to hit me
with the
oaky dose right there
[Music]
that was so funny oh wait no we can't
back up there uh let's go around here to
market side
oh try to go quickly and mark the side
quickly yeah yeah
hold on the heck kind of swipe
vision for days yeah they have a charge
i heard major shuffling and i was like
hold up i'm unloaded in here actually
oh sorry i'm watching here though
because that squad might come
here or i might come here definitely
what music genre do i like i like all
kinds of music to be honest
damn i wish i had my oh she backed up
she backed up
[Applause]
well she cute
there's another one though
i don't see a report in the corner
oh
oh and now the other team came in
spicy
wow
[Laughter]
we are only in the lower bracket we're
on olympus
let's get some olympus games in there
real quick
real quick
it's honestly really hard to tell in
this mode like
who's on which team how many teams are
actually there
so it's kind of exciting though because
it like shakes things up a little bit
i definitely did not think there was
another team back there
constantly stressed
you know science
let's go
look at this lot you don't know what
you're in for
as long as i don't jump off yet this is
your champion i know right
someone jump off
okay we got a second chance second
chance on bonsai i know right
nothing can go wrong this is actually
great practice to practice like hot
spots
landing
[Music]
someone's going on the bottom of this
building we're landing on
someone
batter enemy down nice i don't have a
shield or a gun
she quit
hello
oh no they drop back down they're just
like teasing it i guess
on a
oh
oh my goodness this is gonna be hold on
hold on
oh there's another one here
[Music]
cracked fused nice
yeah i need to get out of here i'm in
the corner in the corner
okay okay they're they're gonna drop
down on us though
no what what they're on the other side
oh my god that those art stars though
out here trying to ruin my life
[Music]
oh my goodness okay
[Music]
oh i think i just saw something flash up
there there's a fight happening in solar
array right now
[Music]
what is on my gun do you see this on my
gun
there is something on my gun
i'm confused wait wait let me let me
wait for the uh for the
tree to catch up hold on there's
something on my
alternator it's like oh i see it yeah
that's that's a visual glitch
no i'm good
all right we're good we're good okay i
was like yo
this is crazy um where are we going yeah
i'm pretty low on ammo yeah
and i don't i have double light gun like
a goon
so you know if you see like a
hemlock or something i know
are they back where we came they hadn't
seen us i can't even know
see on the other side of those walls i'm
afraid they didn't push
that's so weird
he was just like no
i think this way but is this out of ring
like
yeah it's not a ring yeah we can go up
this way
and then go in
genuinely when he uses his old you can
like zoom in on it and it's like a
sniper rifle
it's actually yeah i was watching um
ryan play i was like what the heck is
that
uh
got to
actually bins look close i actually have
never mind they're open i'm just blood
zero
meds uh i'm dropping a bunch of myths
for you
oh t why
[Music]
definitely solar are you still yeah
uh sniper cycle
well i don't love the sensor something
hmm
wanna go check out estates oh oh
a phase runner i heard something at face
runner
hmm
on my way up okay oh too bad you're not
playing octa in this game
i know try out the uh the epic rotation
epic there is a rampart wall
in that building here
it might go secret tunnel behind this
team fighting okay
well actually i think they're posted up
in there overall
in it
three minutes ago someone was jumping
around yeah
got some people they are popping off in
energy
they are 14 squads left this
[Music]
i think you're over here
i don't know i don't know where to go um
someone's there i saw somebody something
dropped there
saw something fall out of the sky i
don't know what but
it might have been a piece of dust but
you never know yeah best human idk
uh denny can
yeah maybe they just fell off the ledge
i don't know that was weird it
definitely looked like something maybe
they were trying the
rotation and they messed it up
think i can get this beacon without
dying yeah you're good
that's a rez coming out somewhere though
i'll block you with my life
don't crave me bros i know don't do it
don't you even think about it
yeah i feel like we're both trying to
grab the sights that was like on top of
them
i kind of want to go third part of this
team at energy
energy oh they're rezzing yeah they're
right here
just be careful popping off because this
battle over here and energy is right
behind us
yeah i know i'm just taking it i just
took a shot at a guy who was down or who
was um
no shield but they different part of the
energy because this is we can get
here we just check below us yes oh yeah
team coming down
from uh waterfall one has no shields
one is purple one's on the left as well
over here and one find that one
[Music]
uh they're moving back up though okay
yeah shields
people behind us yeah i was like i think
i hear it's moving behind i hear octane
yeah all right let's focus these two
that are close to us
yeah through my old concept
yeah i'm shielding
uh
oh back here yeah yeah i don't know if
they're like moving to get a different
angle or something
but this is the only real ring thing
there's a care package inside the rift
ring i mean it's round no in the rift
over there
okay
i'm taking the long rotation around yeah
yeah yeah
while they're distracted i guess
[Music]
this place looks like was that you
this is people talking all right okay
over there
i might take some shots at them okay
yeah my uh sentinel's amped right now
nice yeah you might be able to get some
good shots yep i see him down
check the right check the right three
i'm going right right now
yep yep yep eyes on right they dropped
they dropped
i hit him for 20. oh up here
there's one behind there as well
41.83
they're gonna rest they're gonna run
i don't know i don't think so but
there's three here still for sure
one's down here there's like a ledge
here yep yeah
i need help i need help i need help i
need help
[Applause]
oh someone's
i just need some not that
all right
i wish we were able to please that
freaking buff
all right i'm gonna check this box for
you
nope keep going keep going throw it down
keep it down
oh it's too far it's too far no
oh my god it's okay last stretch is like
right there
my light flash before my eyes
before your eyes you guys is
oh my goodness thank you heat shield
probably one of the best additions to
the game
i'm completely out of heavy ammo right
now life is sad
double light oh heavy
all right how's everyone on healing
items i have two syringes
i got two extra bats we're gonna have to
start moving again i have many
small syringes
hold on i want to i want to just get
into it
yeah ready casey we just need to take
these guys out so denny can get up
something someone dropped down
they're gonna kill me i'm almost dead oh
no
i'm dead they just gunned me down
degrees
someone's landing on us yeah oh we're
still five here they don't know we're
here
purple shell 32 yeah
oh i missed everything because i didn't
i know there was two in there
behind you behind you once all right
i was just trying to sneak on bye
yeah there is something especially
nerve-wracking about being in that like
small ring
and you hear the respawn like trail fly
in it's
[Music]
oh all right
i do feel like more engaged
in this mode though for sure
which helps i think that's good training
to not linger around an
area too long because i feel like i die
like that all the time
always be stressy
[Music]
yeah you gotta seize the moment where
you know they're shooting at someone
else
i can hear it in there i could hear
their comms
bloodhound team shot i wish all of you
could fight tomorrow too yeah
oh nap maybe in another i mean i don't
want to go in the ring but i'll
land there no no it's boxing yeah all
right boxing ring time
let's see any takers any takers maybe
one oh yeah all right here we go
i'm ready to try jump on all these goals
[Laughter]
i didn't get anything i was just
throwing hands i got my shield
because i did some damage scarier yeah
i think i got a gold backpack from them
nice i got
it yeah i did that's all i got
what it's speaking i don't even know
where
um you have a problem doing what
happened what happened
is someone with you guys i'm at the
other side so um i can't pull out my
guns
whoa no i can't pull out my guns
either oh no no
yeah oh it's a bug actually right right
because what
is that called something else besides
all right all right you guys want to
test something
maybe if we jump off the map because
ladies
and gents
um
[Music]
we are eternally doomed to the fifty
cups
come here come here everyone everyone
everyone come here huddle
up guys settle up all right i'm going to
drop
two grenades for you guys take off your
shields like put yourself yeah i already
took my enough
spot hold up and
i can't even take the grenade out oh
no oh my god okay we're doing it this
way we're doing it this way
guys where we died while we were in the
fight night ring
and when we respond we can't take our
guns out
all right all right uh we're gonna have
to do this
farewell
all right if we respawn and we still
can't then we're just seeing how far we
can get
i'll just be like permanent support
backpack i'll just run around behind you
guys
did they take mobile respawn out of the
i don't think so i
had one last time
is it yep it's a wrap oh my
no what is it
all right you guys we got this all right
we gotta play
the 100 passive run right here
it says going back into the ring and
jumping out again it'll fix it oh okay
okay okay yeah because i keep thinking
fight night but i guess what is it
called pathfinder
oh yeah all right
all right all right we've got one
mission and one mission only
land and get out oh they're
they're right there oh like they're
weird
they just rest yeah in and then we're
getting out
i hope they rise no that's a lie it's a
lie wait hold on
let me do that jump in jump out jump in
jump out no it's not working
it's not working i can't
what toxic actually
let's
all right
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
else lame
i wonder if they're like my guns come on
guns
they're here
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
honestly i felt like things like this
are to be expected in the first day
please respond
i know we will stay here
what if they don't have guns either i
thought
[Music]
wait here to die it's okay it's all
right
oh here so oh okay yeah come on come on
training
join us the fight ring's nice and warm
and bugs
dang i can't even throw my that's the
sound of me trying to throw my cue
bro honestly i hope the final ring is on
fight night
that would be great the only thing but
it's fair
that would actually be amazing i wonder
i wonder
yeah yeah i can't use my tactical
no buttons no super that fun noise
why didn't that seem come and kill us
why are they doing that i wonder if they
also
they were like
they
um
[Music]
hold on i think we all get
i'm surprised no one has come over here
yet yeah i keep trying to jump in here
well what's it like to be a blind
bloodhound
stop like fight us
i really wish
i had to keep the shield just thinking
you can't even
is
is
[Music]
i thought i was being smart and i was
going to take all the ammo in here but i
realized i was probably pulling from all
the ammo i just dropped here i feel like
i heard
someone oh
[Music]
yeah i ain't afraid i ain't afraid
[Music]
yeah 1v1d shoot me with a gun if you're
lame
look at that pile right isn't it
you know enticing
here before like took out her wrist
oh yeah i like bloodhounds because
bloodhound like looks around on the
ground and stuff
you need slash dance honestly
did they really leave they laughed
they were like oh yellow we're just
standing here
menacingly
well guys i hope you're enjoying war
games
at home you know while we sit here come
on
come on be in rings oh no no
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
i would like to side note that this is
all casey's fault for being like let's
go into the fight tonight
let's go throw it
[Laughter]
down with it shift you know what you
know what let's go
i wanna i'm just gonna i know i know you
guys you guys gotta go first
yeah don't shoot me from up now
reported for being lame
i know never again never again
that was fun though okay so sweaty too
what they saw again
it might have been all my fault but it's
fine it's fine you know we learned
something today actually
i feel like that will benefit in the
future
oh man now we
seriously
oh no yeah we just out here respawn
testers
yeah exactly it's all part of the clan
it's all fine it's all okay
oh okay now it's not for a actual
actual game
i did a smooth 60 damage to that wreath
on my way out though
[Music]
honorable yeah dishonorable
all right i definitely need some action
after the after that yeah
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay hold up those numbers
oh i have one bullet left in this g7
it's
it'd be a struggle out here now you have
20 million
oh yes i just found this factory nice
ooh are you
hello hi i don't mind if i don't
i definitely need chill cells
i see red i see
live action dance
oh i'm running out of ammo too this is
bad
they are definitely going to be rushing
in here
i'm out of
[Music]
[Applause]
where do you guys
i'm not gonna lie i'm thoroughly
enjoying moves
i didn't make it over unfortunately
nope crap i did not make it over
just kidding
yeah i really was
vibing with spitfire [ __ ]
yeah i'm about to draw a spitfire with a
cute little face on it because
now i can't get it out of my head
all right i'm dropping i'm dropping the
wingman i can't
i tried
yeah we held it down though right there
we're not gonna lie
for having like nothing yeah that was
pretty legit
a whole lot of
my non-existent
eventually i'll pick up another light
then 37 bullets from my spitfire
oh no that sounds horrible
on the contrary it was a big problem
dang g7 scout was holding me down either
even though i'm
[Music]
[Music]
i have so many syringes
[Music]
half the squads are gone already
fantastic
thanks
my
there's actually a purple barrel in here
uh let me know you see a light mag
anywhere
oh sorry i thought we were getting out
there right here
oh
there's two teams here yeah be careful
they're i'm pretty sure in that building
right across
yeah they are hitting pretty hard but oh
i just
is
[Music]
oh my
oh man i needed a light mag so bad right
there
super bug i thought it was
getting shot from the right but i was
actually just getting shot from the left
yeah oh man our 99 is super good if you
don't got a mag on that
good luck good luck
length
oh
[Music]
with my spitfire and killed two people
yes
this is youtube we love the chaos
[Music]
it was really like clown car thing
that little room someone running in like
oh geez
champion challenger means literally here
pals
plotting a london's one of my
specialities
um i think i'm gonna land on that right
side with the underground
[Music]
it looks like everyone went what's over
there hydroponics that came with us
right to our left on the other side oh
no ac you're right
disclaimer i am not going to hit any
shots with this 30 30.
okay good as long as we all know just so
you guys are aware of the situation
right down there yeah they grabbed an
star
someone's already landing someone landed
on this on
respawn already oh yeah i see that
oh there's someone in the middle
of this one grandpa and someone in there
down there okay i'm following kate yep
i only have a bastard
all righty i know pence again they went
on this side
[Music]
coming down here
[Music]
all right good job good job definitely a
sign i think we can go up
what do you think um i mean we can try
wait aren't we
iceland where are they oh no they're up
here okay
okay okay
this way let's go what's in here
i'm gonna lift up
oh we went up we went up we went up
okay
shoot at me if you're lame oh i hear
someone on the
lift on the left
the charger
keep running keep running
[Music]
i would like to no longer be using this
repeater
i would prefer literally anything
anything
[Music]
no bullets and no mags
blue shells
okay anybody got a light gun i have a
gold mag that i picked up earlier
there you go extended light mag here
level four oh hello
[Applause]
it sounds spicy
open the door on myself almost
at 300 ammo
i'm once again requesting your happiness
you know what that could be completely
valid
i ain't messing with the inside of that
ring anymore
i learned a lesson couldn't even scan
it was quite the experience
oh
yeah exactly turbine yeah
turbine
just snap right now
do you want to go third party that fight
or you want to go underwater
[Music]
[Music]
he's okay
yeah that was like it's definitely near
that right side of turbine over there
oh we can go back now okay
internally externally
in the vent in the vent pathfinder
nice nice
i'll just ruin their lives or something
okay yep
why did my brain do that green
the harmless
[Music]
sooner
every everything's horrible everything
is closing i just want to go over there
i suggest we move yeah
i've been evading
[Laughter]
i'm pretty far behind like three or four
seconds behind you
love it love
watch the flank
don't look over here no one's under here
oh
the crypto drone
that's so funny ah rejuvenated
[Music]
yeah i'm in here
crack one but i'm going
oh this is horrible everything is
horrible
oh yeah i ain't going over there are
they crazy
they could oh man i want that banner
though
i want that banner
they'll never see me land here
[Music]
um
we're out of here oh no not like this
[Music]
oh
i'm using a phoenix
yeah i was like running out of resources
i was like i don't want to fight this
anymore
doing so well
[Laughter]
all right so this is going to be our
last game for the stream you guys so
let's make it a good one
and then yeah thank you guys for tuning
in so far
we've been chilling this new mode is
chaos
and we love it we're here for it yeah
it's actually really fun
that tunnel was itemized went in there
and like could never leave
[Laughter]
that was good
all right the real question is it's our
last game so do we want to go to like
pride go where
to get my troubles sure
our favorite place i mean i mean i do
like fighting there
i just don't like when i land and i
don't get new things i'm like this is
supposed to be a good area
yeah i like elysium until whoever lands
in the middle
gets like look at this chill
but like when we get there it's like
zambia
is a champion not bad
for a syndicate dog
[Music]
[Applause]
here we are
a couple teams already dropping in
are we landing the center on the side
okay
i already see no shells in here of
course
love to see it all right
when we land in the center chills don't
exist
oh man
all right all right all right you see
what i mean though like we literally
dropped in the hot zone in the center no
show not even a white shield
i bet oh there's a fight going on
i think i don't even remember how much
ammo i had to be honest
i think there's definitely a spot here
yeah they're fighting
i'm running right upon him they don't
know what's going on
[Applause]
dang he fell under underneath
[Music]
oh
i'm trying to get to you hello
my goodness
i know
all right this is the real last game
because
you know danny got a dc'd it doesn't
count
that's just that's just how it goes
[Laughter]
but yeah i'm definitely having fun today
though thank you guys for joining thank
you casey and danny pawn for playing
oh yes thank you for having us
the chats are vibing having fun too
we're in this together remember
[Music]
hot shots let's say you shoot your way
out of this one right
[Laughter]
for a syndicate dog
we did pretty good there last time
wait hold up nobody dropping here or
what
[Music]
took
thank you our detected
architect yep they're already in the
center i believe on the left
they're chasing me
two cracks
[Music]
yeah i just saw you around the bottom
okay
yeah see you later brandon thanks for
tuning in it's always good to see you my
dude
have a good one
i'm landing on you
okay okay
and then
oh come on yeah oh come on man
i thought locations
normally i would say
we out
say less than uh
[Music]
oh yeah all part of the plan
extremely calculated
scanning the area
scan location talk to my health
yeah i was trying and i keep like
falling off the edge at the same time
[Music]
hold up i'm lagging behind a little bit
okay i'm turning i'm turning hold up
what else is dropping behind you guys
behind behind behind behind behind over
here
yeah oh they're super split up maybe we
should go after this guy up top since
he's by
i don't know where he himself now but
it's better than chasing that guy at the
bottom probably
probably yeah
well another person on the care package
oh
damn oh my goodness
one two three four how many floors hold
on
right now what oh my god bye who
behind me
oh i did not go where i thought
this way you can yeah yep it's gotta
shield up all right other way
out of here i know right it's too spicy
it need mild smiles flavor so much spice
yeah where's that did that tried in like
they're in this building
okay
oh
where are we
you know sometimes you could just sit on
top of a roof somewhere and
no one will ever shoot you that's just
how it works
they're jumping over to me right here
too
okay i'm dead all right where'd you go
okay
you're all ready uh i i was getting shot
and i slid down
and then i went oh i see you
were they on top of you yeah there was
another team on top of that
like ledge on the left but they just
jumped onto our boxes
so i don't think they're on the left
anymore
joke's on you we barely even had stuff
it's a purple shoe
you got this you got this yeah
scenario i think oh no
oh my god
t-shirt two shorts
if only we had
one oh my god nice train
leggies like how do you even get up
there
yeah huh hello
let me throw you a lift from the
afterlife yes
be horizon
[Laughter]
you got this no worries
i do have my wrist though i stole my
talking oh yeah
okay okay you know you know
it's just fun it's fun it's fine
according to plan z
seven squads but 19 people left
oh does that count the um revive
or no no oh no it doesn't
missing a couple i wonder
couldn't be me imagine being dead right
now
all right so what up chat how are you
guys enjoying
the first new ltm second chance
too bad it wasn't third chance or else
i'd still be playing right now
i personally like it so far actually
it's kind of cool
see now the next ltm i think
i think it's the next one but we're
gonna oh no wait i think it's the third
ltn is when you automatically get your
teammates banners
that would have been good right now was
that a stray bullet or were they
actually shooting at you
i don't know
i don't know but i don't want to see
yeah you're like i'm going back over
here
thanks yeah do it
do it do it run across an
open field in a bright red skin what
could possibly go wrong
no one's gonna notice your lava skin
running across
wow they're really not love to see it
looks like i'm inside the ring
everyone's fighting no one sees the wife
they're practically handing oh of course
jumping oh my goodness
that was a part of the plan you know
draw them out into the open so that you
can
you know rain bullets down upon them
from the waterfall
it's all part of that
no one can be done second chance here we
go
surely no one would be inside the
robotics laboratory
i'm just gonna say hello
my nessie shipped i am so excited
yes
big red joe thank you so much for tuning
in we'll see you next time and hope you
have a good day thanks for stopping by
nice super unluted robotics
i'd love to see it
no one saw me come down here not at all
nobody here but us
blueprints and storage boxes
get us the dub casey
[Music]
it's okay no one else is gonna have
their rest by now
yeah we're actually just in a backpack
right now that's all
it's quite cozy in here i must say yeah
yeah
yeah yeah you know okay
i think that's all three teams left over
oh i see i kept seeing people like it
say people committed suicide but that's
them like
early activating their their token right
um okay okay i was like
how are all these people like falling
off falling off the map
yeah just jumping off legends i'm
activating it
makes sense
good the ring is going to land right on
you no worries
all right all right all right i'm back
all right i've been all right all right
oh hello there someone underwater ball
as well
literally like little ants on the
sounds like a sitcom three full squads
in me
no we're in a great spot
oh my goodness
nothing here but us just pushes pushes
yeah bright red bush
[Applause]
they are still up there they are still
upset i felt like you could find a
little hiding spot
behind hammond if they don't watch you
run across the field
nothing here open up in here
still up tap no they're inside
[Music]
[Music]
team on the right yeah how many of these
people have
a respawn token left i'm so curious
yes legit gaming says she got this
i agree
oh they're above you
there's a lot of fighting and no one
does when you tell us there's
[Music]
don't look and don't evade to this
corner and just like go inside or
something
there's no zips here so that means that
was a pathfinder zip right and yeah
andrew squads left
he was swinging
three squads oh my goodness oh my
god let's go casey let's go
oh wait see that's the thing we don't
know how many of them are actually
dead zen
oh that was it let's go kc1v3 these
poles
asked would be three
just me easy clap
easy clap i don't know where they
are though if i can get the first shot i
think they were outside
so they might be pushing inside now good
day i'm inside the ring
maybe the path all right you know what
i'm gonna be a little loud yeah i don't
know who works
let's get loud oh
you got this you got this
let's go casey winning
uh-huh
oh no it was empty
hey nice try you got us to second please
that's pretty good um
um does kills go to our stats in this
event it definitely does because i
definitely have gotten a few myself so
it has to alright you guys well
that is gonna be a wrap for a game spot
live cd
had a ton of fun if you guys enjoyed the
stream
then be sure to leave a like subscribe
drop us a follow
also drop a follow to my teammates
jennypond and caseyrios
um if you follow me on twitter i
definitely tagged them in the suite so
you can check it out
um and this is the first of a bunch of
new ltms that's headed towards apex in
the next few weeks
i'm gonna try to stream some of the
other ones we'll see
maybe maybe not but if you do want to
see more then let us know and maybe
we'll do it
so thank you guys so much for tuning in
it was a blast and we'll see you next
time
have a good one
you